le village préféré des français 2021 et
le village de sancerre les
téléspectateurs ont voté et ils ont fait
de sancerre petit bourg de 1500 âmes
perché sur son rocher le village préféré
des français
ce jeudi matin les habitants ne boudent
pas leur plaisir très fier un peu
surpris aussi
à vrai dire au départ j'y croyais pas
trop quoi je suis surprise je pensais
qu'on serait dans les deux troisièmes
on pensait quand même être dans les
premiers mais papa premiers du
classement
c'est super c'est super on a gagné voilà
très beau village c'est mérité c'est
mérité
j'ai eu beaucoup de travaux de fed la
ville et s'est embellie au fil des
années donc moi je trouve ça justifié
justifié et oui car sancerre petite cité
de caractère a su mettre en avant ses
atouts son patrimoine architectural son
vin connu un peu partout dans le monde
et son fromage
elle a ainsi fait la différence après
une année très difficile
les commerçants espèrent profiter de
l'engouement je pense qu'on va avoir un
flux touristique qui va être accrue
surtout sur cette année la sueur sur
cette saison et bien sûr on va pouvoir
avoir un peu plus de visibilité sur la
france plus que dans notre petit sens et
revoir natale
c'est que du positif aussi bien pour
tous les commerçants pour notre village
c'est important et on espère avoir
beaucoup montrent que ça nous apporte
plein de bonnes choses du côté de la
mairie on espère également des retombées
je les imagine nous les imaginons tous
des visiteurs bien évidemment
supplémentaires j'espère aussi des
habitants supplémentaires qui vont venir
acheter des maisons
et puis des nouveaux commerces aussi
j'espère que toute une dynamique se met
en place l'année prochaine
sancerre aura son timbre aussi emmiyan
neuf cent mille exemplaires
une autre façon de rayonner